four massive steel pylons are sunk into
the floor of the North Sea they're going
to be the legs of the brave ton
their movement is controlled from the
bridge the second officer propia
kotovsky and captain tony kato are
intensely focused
a load of more than 20 thousand tons is
being put in place centimeter by
centimeter it's a special moment even
for an experienced seaman and we are
expecting to have four point three
meters penetration at that location
where the water depth is 40 meters all
this operation will take approximately
three hours before we're going to reach
our work in a cup which will be
approximately 30 meters the brave turn
is now a stable platform it's being
jacked up as they call it Piatra pia
kotovsky is not yet permitted to jack up
the ship but if he wants to become a
captain on an installation ship he'll
have to learn how like his boss
Englishman Tony Kaito Kaito has been in
the offshore business for five years
after we've jacked up we can remain in
position throughout any pretty much any
weather conditions we can survive what
we would call a 50-year storm ie the
worst weather you would expect in 50
years
so even if a 10 meter wave rolls on past
will be high enough out of the water
that it won't be a problem to us
now the installation workers get to work
they want to take advantage of the lack
of wind tower parts 1 2 & 3
on top of the towers go the turbine
housings
meanwhile on deck the nightshift workers
have just got up they take over in an
hour
Rene Flixel is on the night shift
he was a Bundeswehr soldier for four
years then underwent additional training
he felt drawn to the North Sea like
everyone else who works here what I like
is the 14:14 rhythm working for 14 days
than 14 days off you can plan things at
home you know you'll be home in 14 days
and you can organize your appointments
around this schedule and you know that
in 14 days you'll be back on the job
everyone here says they earn a lot more
than in their old jobs on land but none
of them are permitted to reveal details
on camera
but it's not a trade secret that room
and board on the ship of free cooking is
Bogdan Patton's job today we said
schnitzel gold cordon bleu Bogdan works
alone
I can more concentrate about job it is
not too much people the polish chef
cooks for a crew of 60 vegetarians are
rare at sea the men always want plenty
of meat Bogdan uses no instant of
prepackaged food his men eat plane fare
but freshly prepared conversation with
guys is much better because his good
contact I don't know I knows what to do
and I know squad meet people here and
these guys would prefer on deck Rena
Fraxel begins his grueling 12-hour
workday picking up where the day shift
left off
the crane carefully lift the 100-ton
carbon-fiber rotor Renee and four
colleagues used special cables to
position it without bumping
renee has helped build 40 offshore wind
turbines he prefers working in the tower
to being on deck
the huge constructions have to be bolted
together but today others have done it
but he does show us some of his tools
this is a 90 centimeter wrench I think
it weighs about 8 kilos turning it is
hard work so we use it in rotation you
couldn't do it all alone and that's why
not many women work in this business
it's physically very demanding well some
women do work on the brave turn nothing
here would function without the
stewardesses they make sure everyone on
the vessel feels at home more on that
next week